mon seul regret dans la vie est de pouvoir jouer d'
un instrument pourquoi toi musicien sous sédation
es-tu un saxophoniste très brillant hmm
je joue ces chansons tristes avec tellement de
sentiments ouais c'est un super cadeau je l'
aurais épousé mais c'était un dogmatique
vraiment toi  sais je vois que je n'aime pas les
désordres dopants ouais eh bien je l'ai essayé
quelques fois et j'étais comme lui est-ce que tu as
fumé du frigo j'ai même essayé de l'opium
regarde toi quel était le chem Akira quel
était l'effet oh je  Je n'ai pas aimé non, je
n'ai pas de personnalité addictive, n'est-ce pas,
mais les Mongols bougent, la
technologie sexy moldue les reefers mais vous l'
appelez il a attrapé la tasse qu'il a faite alors vous avez
épousé un musicien mmm-hmm j'ai épousé un
agent de change